100 years ago this month the 19th
amendment to the constitution was
ratified
granting women the right to vote and to
celebrate
a team of women skydivers has been
touring the country
jumping in the various cities that
played key roles in the fight for a
woman's right to vote
including a demonstration jump right
here in new york
nancy chin has the story
soaring in the sky above new york before
vaulting fearlessly from thousands
of feet up it's a pro skydiving team
composed of
all women i think the average jump
number on our team is maybe 10
thousand jobs eleven skydivers from
across the united states
created the highlight pro skydiving team
to celebrate 100 years
this month of women winning the right to
vote
melanie curtis and amy schemalecki are
its founders and captains
do you still get nervous at this point
you're not nervous about
just jumping out of an airplane we know
what we're doing
we just want to do a good job we really
really want to do a good job
and that's what scares us they left to
the occasion with a series of
demonstration jumps and cities pivotal
to women's rights
you get to really connect that these are
real people
and in their day they were doing the
bold brave
thing the team launched their jumps last
month in seneca falls new york
where the first women's rights
convention was held touchdown in
tennessee the state that decided the
fate of the 19th amendment
and dropped by pennsylvania's justice
bell a symbol of the movement
the capstone a demonstration this week
in new york city
on women's equality day they landed in
woodlawn cemetery in the bronx
the final resting place of famed
suffragists like elizabeth katie stanton
we talk about wanting to inspire women
and girls to live bold brave lives of
their own design
and in order to do that we have to be
doing that too
and that is absolutely for me what today
was
shemaleki and curtis say they hope part
of that inspiration
spurs people to vote the team also wants
to encourage more women to take to the
skies
they say only 13 percent of skydivers in
the united states
are female when i was growing up i
didn't think i could be a professional
athlete i thought for sure that was just
for men
it was a belief i had as if it was a
fact and when i started skydiving
and it and i realized this could be my
career
and it was an amazing opportunity for me
that i didn't realize was possible
the team hopes their message carries
more broadly for women and girls
to live fearless lives as trailblazers
of their own
at all altitudes there's also a life
lesson
in there in being bold and brave and
leading into what you're scared of
when my feet touch the ground and yeah
you might not
always win you might not but you're
definitely not going to win
if you don't lean into those moments you
have to
and that's really where you get the
rewards
soaring high without even the sky as the
limit
for cbs this morning saturday nancy chen
the bronx
and i love that both of you now agreed
to go skydiving
i will i've done it twice i did not do
that
i have been banned from any dangerous
behavior
on threat of certain things happening so
we're going to do it as a trio
yeah i can't i will be a great message
a great message it really is